Hello?
Hey, can you hear me?
Daisy?
-Hey.
-Oh, hello.
It's been
a long time, right?
I know.
I literally haven't seen you
for ten years.
-One of them, innit.
-That's mad.
I remember that era
being so special to me.
We were just kids
from a little rinky-dink
home town.
I find it so bizarre
that we found each other.
I know.
I just think our year was
so different to other years.
We were
the gayest year ever.
This is weird.
Wow,
it still smells the same.
Over by the fishies!
This is so cute.
There he is!
Plié!
Over and out, bitches.
-Oh, well, hello.
-Hello.
You are my pot of gold.
Honest to God…
Hey!
I'm sorry, but I wouldn't
put this on the wall.
Josh!
What?
Pull yourself together!
Me and my daughter.
Last day of school!
Say something
about the snow.
It's snowing!
When was
the last time you were here?
It would have been
the last year of sixth form.
Kathleen!
Being on school grounds
and walking around now,
it's just like… yeah.
It's so… It's…
Yeah. It's really weird.
Did you have
lessons in here?
I think when I was
in Year 7.
I sat over there.
Do you remember doing
this self-portrait?
-I hated it.
-Same.
I drew Reese Witherspoon.
No one taught us
how to do the colour right,
by the way.
-What brown?
-Yeah.
-Anyway, here's your seat.
-Thank you.
I'll sit behind the camera.
Just gonna move forward.
We're gonna start
with an icebreaker,
-which is…
-A role play?
Try and name
as many queer people
in our year as possible.
Are we including
the bi people as well?
-Yes.
-Well, you.
-Me.
-Kathleen.
-Owen.
-Josh.
-Lauren.
-Ellie Kelly.
-Kevert.
-Callum Davis.
-Louise.
-Scott came out, didn't he?
Connor Wanklin.
Hannah Williams?
When I started doing drag,
some people were just like…
You'd be surprised.
I'm sure I'm missing
a good few people.
Oh, my God, there's,
like, all these names.
There's loads and they've
all gone out of my head.
You beat Kath.
Kath got about six.
You can just name
our friend group.
This is what happens
when you come to Tewkesbury.
You go gay
and you get filmed.
At the time, in school,
it didn't seem strange
that there were
so many queer people
in our year group.
It just seemed
very, very normal.
Gays in the house!
And it's only really
looking back, realising,
actually, that was
really special because
to have over 30 people
in one year group
identifying somewhere
on the spectrum
in this tiny town
in 2005 to 2012,
not the same
in the year above,
in the year below,
I don't know
how it happened,
but I'm just
so glad that it did.
We call Tewkesbury
Twinkleberry,
or Twink for short.
Good old Tewkesbury.
It's a really
picturesque town,
like the gorgeous old abbey.
It's like a small town
in every sense of the word.
There's always
a mutual friend
that will know who you are.
You generally can't
walk down the street
without someone being like,
"How's your mum doing?"
or, "How's
your grandad doing?"
You're like,
"I just wanna go
and get some bread."
It's like…
It's one of those.
I would say Tewkesbury is
a very white town as well.
Being a mixed-race kid
in this town,
I remember
that I stood out a lot.
You constantly felt like
you were being watched,
so for me, it was just like
I had to have a clean break.
I come home
just to see family,
and on the odd occasion,
to see friends, but…
that is such a small pool
cos I never really felt
at home in Tewkesbury.
I feel like
there is a dark side.
Yeah.
I'd say it's a thing about
any small English town.
There's always undercurrents
of people's secrets.
I don't know. I feel like
I'm talking ill of it,
but I love
Tewkesbury to bits
'cause it's where I'm from
and it's where I grew up,
and I had a great time.
Do you feel like
a bit conflicted
when speaking
about Tewkesbury?
You don't want
to bad-mouth it,
but you should
be able to say
there's bits about where you
grew up that you don't like.
It's just Tewkesbury,
isn't it?
I always felt like
if I had a good day
in school and stuff, like,
then home would be OK.
I knew at an early age
that I was gay,
and for me, I was having
to hold that in.
-Hey, kids.
-Hey!
My first step was
just telling my friends
because if I could
open up with them,
then hopefully then in time,
I could do the same
with my family.
We'd just had PE,
and I remember
telling some friends.
And it was meant to stay
between those guys,
but obviously our year group
being our year group,
everyone found out
really quickly,
and also being in
that small, confined space,
everyone just, like,
found out,
and I don't know,
it was weird
because I'm just expecting
hate to have flooded over,
but everyone was like,
"Oh, my God!
Do you know she's gay?"
And it was just, like…
Everyone was just kinda
happy about it.
And I was just like,
"What's going on?"
And then like the next week,
someone else had come out,
and then it was just, like,
this chain of people then.
I think I was probably
13-14 when I came out.
Look at him!
I remember growing up
and, like, buying
the Baby Spice doll
and I was like,
"No, I need
to have all five girls."
My mum,
she went all the way
to Toys "R" Us,
bought me all five girls,
and I think
she knew by then.
She was like,
"Yeah, he's gay."
I think it was
fairly obvious
with the friend group
we hung out with
that I was gay.
Hi, Mum!
People stopped asking
because any time they did,
they would then get attacked
by my friends
or it'd be like,
"Oh, what of it?"
And then,
there was
this one girl at school
that was basically
a known gossip,
and I thought, "I'm happy
for everyone to know."
Told her,
it then spread out
to the wider world.
I came back in Year 12
and someone asked me once.
"Are you gay?
I heard you came out."
I was like, "Yeah."
And she was like, "Ah."
And that was that,
and then, no one…
no one then said
anything about it again.
I didn't come out.
I think
I really resented the fact
that other people
had to be part of…
this experience of mine.
Girl, you so fine!
I also just like spoke
about liking girls
with my friends,
and that was it.
-Hey, beautiful!
-Hey.
I think there was
the first two or three
people who came out,
and then after that,
I don't think people really
came out to the year.
For the large part,
there didn't seem to be
a lot of judgment.
Do your thang!
Up until Year 9,
I was this, like,
very scared person.
I do remember
doing a paper round
and literally thinking
in my mind, I was like,
"Please don't be gay.
Like, I can't be gay."
In school, I was
two years below you guys.
There was only one
other gay guy in my year,
but…
I don't know, I just felt
more at home with you guys.
Less people would come up
and have something to say
'cause you had
a group of people
who were open and proud
and would fight
the fight with you.
So, I'd spend every moment
I could with you guys.
I just have one thing
for you to read.
Yep.
This is a letter
that we wrote to the MP.
I was 16,
so you would have been 14.
-Did we write it together?
-Yeah. At Ed's house.
It was me, you, Josh, Kath…
Yeah.
Harv and a couple of others.
Could you please
read it out to the room?
Blah-blah… Oh,
these are long sentences!
Here I am calling for gay
marriage to be legalised.
We find it
absolutely disgusting
that even in 2012…
…heterosexual people
have privileges
that homosexual and bisexual
people do not have.
If you were denied the right
to marry a woman,
based on something
as irrelevant
as her race or height…
…I'm sure you'll feel
discriminated against
and want to alter the law.
Please try and see the world
through another
person's eyes.
You're after all
trying to lead
the people of our town.
Wow, that's crazy.
2012. It's not even
long ago, is it?
-So, that was to the MP.
-OK.
And this was from the MP.
Oh! This I have not seen.
Yeah, I don't think
I did share it with anyone.
It's probably
not worth sharing,
but let's give it a read.
Thank you for your recent
email about an article
which appeared
in local press
with regards
to same-sex marriage.
I will have
to disappoint you
by saying that I believe
that marriage
is between a man
and a woman.
I do not discriminate
against people
because of their sexuality.
Indeed, I have friends,
one of which is
a very senior MP,
who are homosexuals.
And, as an aside,
I have friends
from other continents
such as Africa.
I abhor discrimination
and believe that prejudice
is born of ignorance.
I have nothing against
couples of the same sex
having relationships…
…or even cohabiting…
…but I do not believe
that they can be married.
With best wishes,
Laurence Robertson MP.
As a queer person,
I think you just
grow up expecting people,
to a certain extent,
to be homophobic.
Also you remember just
that kind of feeling that
other people were starting
to hate on me,
which wasn't
a feeling I had before.
So… was it me or was it
because I was gay?
I was very reclusive
because I was just
always terrified of people.
It was a constant fear that,
if I went out,
what could happen to me?
People would push me over,
I got spat on.
I got tied to a tree…
and thrown rocks at.
Um, I got pinned down
and someone snotted
a bogey in my face.
I used to always
put myself down
and, um, just make
myself feel like shit…
because I was just so camp
and I just felt like
the other boys
just didn't get it.
And I just remember feeling
really uncomfortable…
with myself, but then,
I guess, growing up,
I felt like I wasn't
on my own.
It's in the windows!
I just didn't
give a shit anymore.
And I still don't, you know?
So, yeah.
I felt that you guys did
look after me.
In a way
that my parents couldn't.
I think if they knew
to the extent,
well, they would have
wanted to help more,
but they couldn't.
So, I found a family,
within school,
of people that were like me.
As a year group,
everyone always
used to look out
for each other.
You were like kind
of protected in a way
'cause you had these people
that were like
that barrier between you
and that hate.
You don't need
to feel alone in it.
There's a group of people
that you can connect with,
somewhere,
maybe two years above.
Even in a tiny little town
like Twinkleberry.
I feel so lucky
to have always had
queer people around me
who were fairly happy
to explore their sexuality
at a time and in a place
where that wasn't
encouraged.
I don't think I've ever
gotten closer
to other people
than the friends
we've had here.
The funny thing is
I still have more gay
friends from this tiny town
than I do from living
in the centre of Birmingham
where there's
a massive gay scene.
It's so bizarre.
The funniest part
is that we're literally
all walking around
calling this town Twink.
I don't know whether people
don't know the gay meaning
of that word.
Twink! Like who…
It's full of twinks!